Alright folks, hello and
welcome.
Uh, today we're gonna be talking about Amazon
EKS auto mode.
I know a lot of you are probably familiar
with reinvent sessions where
they spend 45 minutes telling you how great something
is and then 5 minutes
showing you how it works.
We're gonna flip the script a little bit and we'll start
with the demo showing you what's possible
with Amazon EKS auto mode.
My name is Cy Venom. I'm a principal solutions
architect at AWS.
I'm joined by Alex Kessner,
who's the principal product manager,
uh, and the lead PM for Amazon EKS
Auto mode, and we also have a guest
who'll join us on stage here
in a little bit, uh, from Capital One
as well. So
stay tuned for that, folks. And like
I said, I do wanna go ahead and
start with a demo. I wanna show you folks
what's actually
possible with Amazon EKS
Auto mode.
And we're gonna start here with our familiar
Amazon EKS dashboard, but
don't worry folks, we're gonna go to the terminal here pretty soon.
I just wanna show you what we're starting
with. We're gonna make this just a little
bit bigger first. Uh, we're gonna go
to clusters.
I have a cluster that I created not too long ago,
um, just to show you folks,
there's nothing in the cluster right now. It's completely empty,
so 0 pods, 0 nodes.
But I promise you it's production ready
and I think the interesting thing
about this is that, uh, you know, generally
with any sort of EKS cluster,
uh, when you run get pods and
all name spaces you expect to see some things
in there, anything for,
you know, things like pod to pod networking, maybe
coup proxy,
maybe the CNI, the container networking interface,
but with an auto mode cluster
you're gonna see nothing in there but I promise
you it is production ready.
And I think the first hint
for knowing
whether it's production ready is
uh by looking at the custom resource
definitions in the cluster.
And here's kind of that hint of
you'll see things in here for
like node claims and node pools
that's the underlying open source carpenter
project that
gives us dynamic node auto scaling.
You'll see some indication here that we can
create ingresses and load balancers.
Essentially our cluster
has these components managed in the
control plane
to enable it to be ready to serve
real workloads.
But they're not running in our data plan,
so no nodes,
no pods, nothing that we're responsible
for, nothing that we're paying for, and most
importantly, nothing that we need to manage when it comes
to things like cluster upgrades.
Let's do something a bit more interesting. I'm gonna
clear this out and then in the bottom
terminal load up EKS node
viewer. This is just a tool to let me see
what nodes are in my cluster again, no
nodes and over here I wanna apply a very
simple retail,
uh, store sample application.
And just the UI component
and you know there's no nodes, right,
but in just a matter of a few seconds you saw
Carpenter pick it up and we saw
that it picked a C6A
large instance
um it's not ready yet it's
starting the node any second now it's
at 16 seconds, 17 seconds you can
see on the bottom right
no started
networked into our Kubernetes cluster.
It picked a C6A large as you can see,
and we have one pod still pending
to start but scheduled on that note, right?
In the second here it should switch to
running boom, there we go.
Uh, let's do something a bit more interesting. We're gonna
scale this deployment up to 10 replicas
now. I don't think all 10 replicas are gonna
fit in that first node. Nope, see,
so it fits 3 in that first node.
And then to fit the remaining 7 it's
gonna spin up a C6AX large.
By the way folks, it's deciding the nodes for
me. I didn't
script this ahead of time. I didn't tell it what to do.
It's gonna pick the right node for the right set
of workloads.
Boom, there we go. The node is ready.
The pods are scheduled,
and in a few seconds here we should see them
all flip to running. So there you go. You can see a 10
running. Bound on the two nodes
and the the deployment scaled
up by the way, it's also
working on spinning up an application load bouncer
for me, but that takes a couple of minutes and I'm
trying to show you the full demo in 5 minutes.
So let's clear this out
and poured forward,
uh, the service that we've created here.
And then
once that's ready, switch to a browser.
Here we go and we'll go to local host
and there we go. This is our retail
store sample application.
Pretty basic. Just,
uh, front end UI application. We
did scale it 10 times and so
you saw with the fresh
EKS auto mode cluster we're
able to start serving traffic.
We were able to dynamically scale the nodes
where the workloads work
in a matter of minutes and I think
that's really the idea here, uh,
is we wanna show you
the, the rapid pace of,
uh, how quickly you can start getting workloads going.
So that's my quick 5 minute demo.
I have a deeper dive demo coming here
in a little bit.
This was the what of how things
work, but for us to start understanding
the why,
I wanna pass it to Alex, our
lead PM on EKS auto mode. He's gonna
talk a little bit about how we
got here. Take us back to the beginning.
Off to you, Alex. Awesome, thanks.
Thanks everyone for joining us today. Really excited
to be with you.
Um, you know, I think that,
uh. It's so exciting
to see how quickly you can get started
up and running with EKS Autoode today, but it's also
important to understand why customers choose
Kubernetes and how EKS evolved to get
where we are today with Auto mode.
Stepping back, Kubernetes was created
to help customers manage the increasing
complexity of the cloud.
Today it's the leading cloud operating model, and its popularity
is only increasing.
In 2024, 93%
of organizations, up from 84%
last year, surveyed by the Cloud Native Computing
Foundation, are either using Kubernetes
in production or actively evaluating it for their
organization. Without a doubt, Kubernetes is the de
facto standard for operating in the cloud.
This is because Kubernetes is incredibly
useful.
It has a relatively simple set of APIs
for managing large groups of servers and
coordinating how your applications run across them.
Because it was both born in the era and
from the complexities of the cloud, it also prioritized
consistency.
After all, what good is Simplicity if there's
different versions of Simple for different
applications, let alone all the different places your
applications need to run.
And while Kubernetes itself covers the vast
majority of the functionality that you
need to build, deploy, scale,
and operate any kind of exciting new
application you can think of,
it's also extensible, which makes it incredibly
powerful.
There are currently 195
open source projects managed under the Cloud Native Computing
Foundation and hundreds more landscape
projects which run on, integrate with, or
extend Kubernetes. You can even write
your own. OK, so Kubernetes
is great. I think you all know that, that's why you're
here. Actually, using Kubernetes is great,
but running and operating Kuberne's clusters
can be quite hard.
So this is why 8 years ago, right
here at Reinvent In Fact in 2017, we
launched Amazon EKS.
This was in response to feedback we got from customers
that managing Kubernetes at scale was hard.
They had to monitor, scale and manage the Kubernetes
control plane to meet their requirements for security
and resiliency.
Let alone find ways to integrate their clusters with
other AWS services that their applications needed.
Since then, Amazon EKS has emerged
as the most trusted way to run Kubernetes,
offloading the undifferentiated heavy lifting
of hosting the Kubernetes control plane to AWS
while remaining fully Kubernetes conformant.
This allows customers to focus on how
to run on running their applications instead of
managing their cluster's control plane.
And we didn't stop there.
Over the last 8 years, we've been consistently
busy delivering new features and enhancements
for not only EKS, the AWS service,
but also the broader Kubernetes open source community.
We started with this basic managed control
plane and have steadily added capabilities
for compute management, auxiliary software,
security, scalability, networking, observability,
troubleshooting, and even recently this year, EKS
capabilities itself, a new launch that you should
certainly check out as it's very exciting for
managing operational software on top of the cluster.
With more than 250 launches over the last
7-8 years,
from expanding into additional AWB regions,
reducing pricing, introducing open source
projects, etc.
we've been very busy. We've even created
brand new open source projects like Carpenter that powers
Auto mode, Crow, and ACK that have become
industry standards.
We've gone deep into operating into every
aspect of operating Kubernetes in
what we think might be the largest scale
anywhere. Which is why we
now run 10s of millions of clusters for customers
every year, and this keeps growing.
But when we spoke with some of our customers running
these tens of millions of clusters, they told
us that while EKS made managing clusters
easier, there was still more that we could do
to make deploying and operating Kuberna's
applications easier,
which is why last year at Reinvent.
We launched EKS Auto mode. Um,
Auto mode is not only a major evolution
for easily running, production ready Kubernetes
clusters, it fulfills our vision of how
we think Kubernete should operate in the cloud.
AutoMode provides Kubernete's conformant
and AWS managed compute,
networking and storage for any new or
existing EKS cluster.
This makes it easier for you to leverage the
security, availability, scalability
and operational excellence of AWS
for your Kubernetes applications.
Auto mode allows you to create application ready clusters
like the one that you just saw from Psy at the beginning of this
talk, uh,
preconfigured with the essential capabilities and
best practices from our 7 years, 8 years,
excuse me,
um, of running tens of millions of clusters.
Dynamically scales and cost optimizes
cluster compute based on your application's needs.
It selects provisions, secures,
and upgrades AWS managed EC2
instances within your account using AWS
controlled access and life life cycle
management. And it handles operating
system patches, health monitoring,
updates, and limits security risks with ephemeral
compute, strengthening your strengthening your
security posture by default.
Autoode also meaningfully simplifies cluster
upgrades,
reducing the operational overhead of running
Kubernete's clusters, enabling you to
focus on the activities that are critical to your business
instead of maintaining infrastructure.
All of these features help reduce the time
it takes to launch new applications and allows
your organization to get new products or modernized
applications to market faster.
Because Automotive Kubernetes conformant, it
means you're able to do so while continuing to take advantage of
that vast ecosystem of open source
tools and software.
Auto mode helps improve your application's availability
as well
by managing the infrastructure
where your applications are running,
you're better able to meet the needs of your users
and organization.
Finally,
it does all of this while automatically
optimizing for cost efficiency both of the compute
and your team's time.
Reducing the operational overhead of running Kuberne's
applications enables you to focus on again
those things that are critical to your business,
so. I've talked a lot about the work
that it takes to manage
all of these Kubernes clusters and the infrastructure behind
them. Let's take a look at what that actually looked like
practically speaking,
before EKS Auto mode.
Customers had to provision a cluster, install
all the essential Kubernetes plug-ins required to
run production grade applications, select,
configure, and launch the best compute
for those applications, and finally
with those pieces in place,
they could finally deploy the applications into their cluster.
But this is just the beginning of actually running these
applications. With the applications deployed,
you now have to you have to continuously monitor all
of this infrastructure and software, repairing
it when unexpected issues inevitably arise,
and upgrading it as new Kubernetes versions
or operating system patches are released so
they can remain up to date, compliant and secure.
All of this was operational work that you had to take
on, which was reflected in the architecture
of a non-auto mode
cluster.
So let's come back and look at, see
what this looks like with EKS auto mode.
With just one click or API call, Auto
mode provides a fully automated AWS
managed Kuberras conformant compute,
storage and networking for any EKS cluster.
Once you've created a cluster with Auto mode enabled, there's
nothing else you need to do before you can begin deploying
applications like you saw from Psy.
Auto mode automatically provides the infrastructure
your applications need.
Uh, scales resources to meet your
application's changing demand,
automatically optimizes for cost, and monitors
and repairs nodes as needed.
All of this eliminates a ton of operational work
so that you and your teams can focus on building
applications that drive innovation.
So the other way you can think about this is what
is the architecture of a cluster look
like both without auto mode and with auto mode.
So here's what it looks like for a
cluster without auto mode. Um,
the classic AWS managed cluster
control plan is on the left in an AWS account,
and all of the other Kubernetes plug-ins, software,
infrastructure provision, and other AWS resources
that your applications need are on the right
in your account.
With auto mode,
this changes quite a bit.
You can see that not only does AWS run
the cluster control plan as we always have, we
also now run a set of essential and integrated
Kubernetes capabilities for compute, storage
and networking.
Straddling our and our customers' accounts,
Autoode also launches EC2 Managed
Instances, a new operating model for
EC2 shared by similar features
in ECS and Lambda, just announced even this
year. This allows you to delegate
operational responsibility for the instances themselves
to an AWS service like EKS with
auto mode while they continue to reside
in your account and function otherwise like
normal EC2 instances.
Other supporting infrastructure
resources like load balancers and EBS volumes
continue to exist in your account as they have
since EKS launched.
You know, one other way that we like to think about
how the balance of what
each of us is responsible for changes with
auto mode is with the shared responsibility model.
This shows what part of
an architecture is our responsibility and what
part a customer is responsible for.
With standard EKS clusters,
we're responsible for all of the
AWS global infrastructure, foundational services,
as well as the cluster control plane.
Well, everything above that in this diagram
from cluster capabilities to compute and
compute life cycle management, operating system
patching, monitoring, repairing,
all of these are fundamentally our
customers' responsibility.
While some of the 250+ features
we've launched over the last 8 years have helped make
managing parts of this easier,
they're ultimately in your
sphere of responsibility to manage.
With auto mode, we move this boundary of the
shared responsibility model considerably.
We take on far more of the undifferentiated
heavy lifting, including all cluster capabilities
for compute, storage and networking,
but also operating system patching, monitoring,
health, and repairing the EC2 instances
where applications actually run.
This lets you focus on your application, your
application security, how it's monitored,
how it's operating, and any other essential plug-ins
or add-ons that you might need.
This lets you focus on the things that are essential to your
business as opposed to managing infrastructure,
of course.
It's one thing for me to tell you about how
great Automotde is, but it's another to see it yourself,
which is why I wanna hand it back over to Cy to go
a little bit deeper in his next demo.
Alright, let's do it, folks.
Thanks for that,
Alex, and I, by the way, these last
two slides, I just like flipping back and forth
between them really fast, and then you can
see just how much we'll manage
for you with auto mode, right? I, I,
it's just, uh, something I like, but the operational
overhead that I couldn't offload was figuring out
how to do that in PowerPoint.
There you go. Uh,
that's why I'm here. That's why I'm here, Alex. Alright,
awesome. Well, it's time to flip into
a demo. Let's see auto mode in action, folks.
I gave you a quick 5 minute,
just very quick flow and
how all of this stuff works, but
how about
we jump back to where we were.
So essentially we had deployed the UI
application. We had scaled it up,
but I wanna do something a bit more
interesting. I don't think any
of you folks have seen any other speakers talk
about JN AI at this conference, right? No.
Well, let me be your first. Uh, we wanna show
you folks a real
meaty LLM model deployed
in EKS auto mode
from scratch on an Nvidia-based
instance. We wanna show how accelerated
compute and this kind of GPU
support comes
batteries included in an auto mode
cluster and hopefully.
It'll give you a good sense for
how much we're actually trying and helping
you manage on the operational side of the world.
So first I'm gonna downscale
these. So let's go ahead and
run a um scale command,
and I'll just take this deployment down to
0 replicas.
Uh, by the way, that autocomplete is courtesy
of Quiro CLI.
Check it out. Um, OK, and, and
just like that you can see in a
matter of seconds, uh, honestly
instantly
those nodes are now at 0% utilization.
They're underutilized,
so what do we expect to happen? Well,
you'll see for yourself. Um,
next what we wanna do here is apply
a node pool
that is gonna be our kind of accelerated
compute here.
OK, what do I mean? Uh, essentially, well,
if we wanna run an LLM,
we can't just run it on basic CPU
memory-based instances.
We need a proper GPU attached,
and we want
an Nvidia GPU.
So let me open up Quiro again,
my favorite code editor.
Of course, and uh we're gonna, we're gonna
go to the GPU node pull. Let me scroll down and
just let me show you folks how you
configure a node pull
before we kind of took it for granted, there's a general
purpose node pull that comes with every EKS auto
mode cluster that's gonna let us deploy
general purpose workloads. But if we
wanna do something more interesting
and most of the time you're gonna wanna do something custom
for your workloads, you're gonna wanna customize the
type of nodes you deploy.
And you may remember with managed node groups you would
have to kind of explicitly list out
all the type of instances you wanna use and
it configures an ASG an auto scaling
group, and,
uh, you know, it integrates with cluster auto scaler
and there's just a lot going on there with
Carpenter,
uh, the underlying open source project that
powers the dynamic node auto scaling
in EKS auto mode.
Instead of,
you know, building up the list of instances,
we filter down based on our requirements.
We tell it we want, um, instances
that are either spot or on demand, and if we're
lucky today, we'll get a spot instance which is
major cost savings on uh
G6 G5 instances.
Um, we also want it to be in
the G class, so G5, G6,
uh, greater than instance
generation 4 again, so we get those two that
we're looking for, and of course within
those instances there's large X
4X large, so on and so forth,
um, and we give it an architecture as
well. So we're telling Carpenter, here's
my requirements,
figure out what I want, right?
All right, let's, let's keep going here. I'm gonna go back to
the CLI and actually apply
the deployment.
So recently OpenAI open source
their GPT models they call the GPT
OSS. I'm gonna deploy the 20
billion parameter model which does require
a a pretty good Nvidia
instance GPU.
So as soon as I created that, you can see
here about 8 seconds ago it decided
to spin up a.
54 X large on oh hey, by
the way, take a look at these two instances
uh that we had scaled down from earlier
you can see they're already scaling down those nodes
are being deleted because we're consolidating
and by the way, if we scale to like 3 instances
rather than 0, it would probably have removed
one of the instances,
OK. This 20
billion parameter model is
14 gigs, so while
it decides to pull the image and take some
time, we're gonna switch gears here and
take you to the console. We're gonna go back to that in
a minute here and earlier I cheated
a bit and we started with an existing auto mode
cluster. It was version 1.33.
I do wanna show you how we create a cluster, but
over here if we go down to
the version of the cluster itself,
uh, we can see we can upgrade it to 1.34
and also there's a create backup
button here. So one important thing to
understand here as a customer of,
um,
uh, of, of, of consumer of auto mode,
you get to decide when to upgrade the
control plane.
We won't take that over for you. This is a major
operation and you should be in control of that.
But we do control the node upgrades,
all the components that, uh, Alex showed
earlier, right? Maybe I can just quickly jump
back to that slide, um,
and show you folks all those components that might be
running inside a cluster.
We'll upgrade those for you as well. Uh,
you don't have to worry about the worker nodes next
time they're restarted, they'll be in the latest version as
well. This makes your life
easier
and you know, take some of that undifferentiated
work and gives it to us. I do wanna quickly
call out this create backup button.
Uh, essentially, um, uh, just, uh, uh,
a few weeks ago, maybe a month ago, we
announced support for,
um, Amazon EKS and AWS
backup. So now with the click
of a button you can back up your clusters,
which we tell you it might be a good idea to
do before you upgrade your cluster. It's up
to you, but it's an irreversible action to
upgrade the control plane version of your cluster. So
you might wanna create a backup and with AWS
backup it's that much easier.
Just a quick call out. OK,
let's get back into. It so this is our
existing cluster, but I wanna show you folks
how to create a fresh cluster. So we'll go to clusters,
hit create cluster,
and we have this relatively
new, uh, quick configuration flow
with EKS auto mode clusters. You can go to custom
configuration and set everything as well, but
we wanted to show you,
yes, buzzword incoming, a one click
deploy option
for auto mode. Um, let's zoom in
here a little bit and just go through the options.
We'll scroll down.
We can, uh, randomize a name
for the cluster, so
serious pop crab. I like it.
Let's scroll down,
uh, pick a version, and then look,
I know
Kubernetes SRE experts
that still stumble around creating cluster
roles and node roles.
We made this easy for you. Hit create recommended
role. You click, click, click, and we'll make one for you.
In this case, I happen to have a couple of roles in
the uh account that I can already use.
Makes life easier.
I know a lot of you probably use EKS Cuddle out
there. This does that for you. Well,
now we do that for you in the console as
well. Um, OK, let's scroll
down here. We have the VPC
that's preloaded and the subnets as
well, but I actually wanna dive into
something, um, a bit more interesting
here. If we go to this quick configuration
defaults, there's a section here. Let me just zoom
in here so you can see it a little bit better.
Um, OK,
so essentially with any auto mode cluster
these are the components you get out of the box and again I
know we've talked about this before, but I really wanna
drive this in. So application load balancing,
when we create,
uh, a, a service and we need load balancers,
application load bouncers or network load balancers,
we'll look at the Kubernetes objects you deploy and
create
the kind of, uh, corresponding resources
in the AWS back end that comes out of the box,
block storage, the EBS CSI driver.
Container storage interface just the way
that Kubernetes is able to help you
create back-end storage for staple
workloads that comes out of the box as well.
Compute auto scaling, I think you all know what this is. I
said it like 5 times already. It's Carpenter. It's
an underlying, uh, open source project
that we open sourced a few years ago.
Um, we'll handle that for you as well.
And folks at Carpenter, if
you've ever set it up before, there's some roles you
gotta set up. There's, you know, you have to deploy
maybe a managed node group for it.
You don't have to. We're gonna run that in our control plane.
GPU support. That means batteries included,
right? Again, I, I said that before. Essentially
any time, you know, if you didn't
leverage auto mode,
you're, you're doing this thing where you have to line
up the kernel version of your Amazon
machine image and the and the
instance, um, to the device,
uh, device driver version
for Nvidia.
You also have to install the Nvidia device
plug-in. And then maybe you, yeah, you want
tools like the DCGM
Nvidia exporter if you're familiar with that. It
gives like in Nvidia logs to Prometheus,
I think that's data center GPU
manager, DCGM exporter that
comes out of the box for you.
And then these last couple of bullet points for Q proxy,
VPCCNI,
core DNS.
I know it's like a ton of acronyms. Just know
it's like pot to pod networking. It's the networking
that any Kubernetes cluster needs.
We handle that for you as well.
That means not just that you don't have to
worry about the nodes they run on,
also that we'll upgrade them for you, right?
So, uh, those are all the components that come
with it, and we'll scroll back down
here and we can hit create. And so
now you see, you know, what I had to do
to prepare.
The cluster for the 5 minute demo
that I had done earlier. You hit create and you're
good to go.
OK, now hopefully I've given it enough time.
It looks like that pod has been
scheduled,
um, on that G54X large from
earlier. Remember this is the GPT
OSS 20 billion parameter model.
We're just gonna describe pods. There's only one, so it'll
come back very quickly,
and I wanna call something out here.
Um, we successfully pulled
the GPT OSS model from my private ECR.
I put it in the ECR before this talk. Um,
it's 14 gigs, right? You
can see that. I think it's 14 billion bytes,
and it was able to pull that
in just over a minute.
Quick tech recap,
couple of years ago, uh, AWS open
sourced a project called Sochi.
Back then it was for lazy loading, but later
on we released a capability called Parallel
Pull. Essentially it allows you
to pull multiple layers of a Docker
image
concurrently.
Now with generative AI it's
extremely important, you know, that time to first
token should be as low as possible,
so pulling a 14 billion
byte model, right? 20 billion parameter,
14 gigs in a minute,
uh, well, before Sochi that would
take 2 to 3 minutes. So that's already
such a dramatic improvement.
With auto mode we can figure that for you
out of the box,
uh, on these uh on these G instances
for example we get that parallelpo
offered by Sochi out of the box ready
to go and this really shows
you kind of
the things that
I didn't have to do to make this
demo work.
I, I mean you guys saw it. It was a
fresh auto mode cluster.
I applied, uh, the, the
configuration. Uh, essentially, uh,
a deployment that had one deployment
and one service,
and it integrated with the Nvidia GPU
drivers. It gives me the logs that are streaming
to Prometheus. I have Sochi parallel
pole support out of the box,
all of these things that
I didn't have to do that are
handled for me, um, and that's, that's
what I mean by,
you know, batteries included. Another way to think about
it is the infrastructure for auto mode
is GPU aware.
OK, I think we've given enough time, by the way,
after the model pulls it then needs to
start it, which takes a couple of minutes.
I think we've given it enough time. Let's switch
to another tab here. We're just gonna
port forward, um, that
service that we created earlier,
the GPTOSS service.
Boom, there we go.
Now let's ask it a simple question. I have a copy
paste here. It's gonna curl that local
host 8000.
As it what is machine learning,
and
I piped it to JQ just to make the pretty output.
OK, taking a look here we can
see it's a thinking model. So
the reasoning here is what is machine
learning. They expect a concise explanation
and there we go. There's a response.
So essentially what did we
show here?
Essentially it's uh infrastructure
that moves at the speed of your ideas,
right? It's we, we wanted to run an
LLM inference workload.
We have a deployment. We wanted GPU
based instances.
We first created a node pool.
We told the node pool the type of.
Uh, nodes that could support this
workload and then we created the deployment
itself. And really
when I was thinking about how to make an
exciting demo for Auto mode, it, it,
it was really showcasing all the things I
didn't have to do. It was the, the streamlined
experience and so hopefully I
got the point across of it, it, it
really is that easy, uh, to,
to deploy even the most, you know,
meaty
like, uh, production ready,
like a 14
gigabyte LLM model, um,
in a matter of minutes,
OK. So I know a lot of you
have the question on your mind right now
this is all great for a demo,
but what about for a regulated
a high scale
environment?
Well, to talk about that I would love
to introduce.
Dan Levine from Capital One.
To talk a little bit
about how they started using
Amazon Ecas Auto mode and how they got
to where they are today.
Here you go, Dan. Hey folks,
thank you very much, Cy, for the introduction.
My name's Dan Levine.
I've been working at Capital One for
about 8.5 years now,
and my main focus has been the implementation
and maintainability of
Kubernete's at scale.
Like Cy said, Capital One is a highly
compliant, highly regulated company
that needs things to be risk averse.
In order to do that,
we need certain assurances to use a
technology like EKS Auto.
So, I'm gonna talk about a few things today.
I think the thing that might be most poignant
for all of you is a little bit about our journey.
We didn't get here
overnight.
There's been 10 years of build-up since Kubernetes
has been released
that led us to the decisions to adopt
EKS Auto mode.
I also wanna talk about some of the solutions
that we've come up along the way to make it
more palatable to be used
in an enterprise such as ours.
Of course this is an EKS Auto talk. I wanna talk
a little bit about EKS Auto. I wanna talk
about the benefits that we've received from
EKS Auto and our enterprise and
a little bit about how our users
are using EKS Auto.
So, like all good speeches,
let me take you back 10 years
to when Kubernetes was first born, and
a lot of different platform teams
within Capital One were trying to implement
Kubernetes. We were bootstrapping EtsyDs,
we were managing control planes.
We were doing all of this in several different
areas of the business. All of these platform
teams that thought that Kubernetes
was a right use case for them
had different opinions about how to do all
of these things.
It was a challenge,
created a lot of arbitrary uniqueness
within our enterprise,
and we weren't able to solve a lot of problems
quickly.
Now, the three main challenges
that we hit because of this
were a high SRE effort,
constant churn, and scalability
issues.
High SRE effort because
everyone's doing something a little bit differently.
They're spending a lot of hours trying to figure
out how do I do this correctly.
High churn because
in Capital One, we have a set of compliance
software that needs to run on Kubernetes
within the enterprise.
This software needs maintained,
updated,
and controlled.
Scalability because
frankly Kubernays was a little young at that point
in time but also nobody was
working together on a centralized
solution. So what do
we do? We moved to
a centralized solution.
We called it the federated
model.
Now within Capital One, we decided
that Kubernetes and at the time EKS
should be
managed by centralized tooling that
a team should carefully curate
for all of the platform teams within the enterprise.
These platform teams would then be
able to contribute more to the
business value that they were actually creating
with their platforms
now. In order to do that, we
had some tenants.
We had some core principles that we
really wanted to enforce to make sure
it could work at the scale that we needed to.
We had several platform teams that wanted to
use Kubernetes.
Those tenants were to be able to meet
our platform teams where they were.
We wanted to do it with them
and not for them.
So
we created a sense of shared ownership and
empowerment
across the enterprise with our platform teams
that use Kubernetes to ensure that they were
getting the product that not only they wanted.
But they liked
But how did we do that?
We looked upstream.
We looked at Kubernetes to see how it was kind of
solving this problem
within the community,
and we used
a concept that they've invented the
special interest group,
or SIG.
When we had critical challenges within our
enterprise,
we would create a SIG
that involved
some subject matter, and that SIG
would solve the problem.
We needed to ship metrics off to somewhere.
You'd get the engineers that had the
pain
and the people that were passionate about the problems
in the same room, in the same SIG,
to solve these problems.
All of their solutions would then
come right back to the centralized tooling
that we maintained and pushed out to the platform
teams. This was great.
We were operating at a, at a higher scale,
we were innovating, we were doing Kubernetes
in a mature manner,
but. We still had some pain.
Two areas primarily that we experienced
pain was infrastructure management.
And container management.
Infrastructure, when you get to the level of
scale that we did.
You need to make sure that you're patching OS's,
you're, you're using the right instances.
You're not overprovisioning and spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
dead air CPU cycles.
Container management because like I said
before we had compliance software
that needed to be pushed out to every
single cluster.
That software needed to be maintained.
It needed to be updated.
We were spending hundreds and hundreds
of hours
maintaining all of this and making sure
that it was doing the right thing in our enterprise.
And it caused a lot of friction.
And that's where we get to today.
That's where we get to
EKS auto mode.
EKS Auto mode,
like Sy and Alex have been
saying, manages a lot of that for us.
AWS is in the business of taking away that
management pain because frankly, I've
used Kubernetes for a long time. I don't
wanna manage it anymore.
I've been doing it enough.
Now I know what you're thinking
before I kind of say how EKS Auto addresses
the pain,
I do wanna acknowledge
you don't take a massive financial
institution, switch on auto mode on a
Monday and say,
great, that's terrifying.
There's several things that you need to do
in order to adopt, and I wanna talk about that adoption
really quickly.
We decided that
to dog food EKS auto mode,
we would use it
with our central delivery platforms. The
centralized team
that created the tooling.
Well, let's throw EKS Auto at that.
Once that was working,
once the control plane was behaving like we
expected with all the software and compliance containers
that we were handing it.
We didn't have promises, we had data.
We had actual proof that
EKS Auto was solving the problem that we
believed it to.
Once we did that, the conversation became a lot
easier. And that data
was addressing the two pain points
that I talked about earlier.
Automated infrastructure management.
Carpenter backs EKS auto mode.
With Carpenter in EKS auto mode,
we no longer have to worry about
am I provisioning the right instances,
am I using CPU that I don't need,
we give it a deployment,
we let it run,
Carpenter does the rest.
It's managed for us.
Also
Simplified container management.
My team is no longer spending hours
and hours focused on upgrading containers
like EBS CSI driver or the
load balancer controller that are table stakes
to run a Kubernetes cluster
at scale,
within a massive enterprise.
Right now we're looking at some other use cases
for this. The two primary ones for us
are machine learning.
In a multi-tenant platform,
these make great use cases for EKS Auto mode
because of the scale that they have,
especially in a multi-tenant platform
that has several different applications, a
platform team won't have to worry about
what they're throwing at the cluster again.
They deploy it,
schedules,
the workload and infrastructure is handled for us.
Now, Just to
close here, there's been a lot of key metrics
that we have deemed
valuable in our usage of EKS A,
but I think one of the best ones is one that's
a little more intangible.
It's silence
And what do I mean by that?
Well, before EKS auto mode,
a lot of our customers would come to us and
they'd say, hey, why is my managed node
group not updating?
Why is EBS CSI driver stuck in
a crashback loop? Why isn't it on the version
that I need it to be on?
And now
with that. Our Slack channels
are silent.
Nobody's asking any more questions around
these problems that we were dealing and spending massive
amounts of hours troubleshooting with our
platform team partners,
and that silence
is golden.
So with that I'd like to close and hand
it back over to Alex to talk a little bit
about some of the great features that they've delivered
over the last year with EKS Auto mode.
Thank you very much. Thanks, Dan.
Appreciate it, Dan.
Dan, stay on stage with us. It's all good,
um.
You know, so one of those features, for example,
is this Sochi parallel poll and unpack
feature. We just launched that this fall,
dynamically drastically reduces
container startup times and just one of the
many things that we've been working on,
you know, just like those 250+ features
that EKS itself has been launching over the last
8 years,
EKS Audible has been busy responding to
customer feedback and building new capabilities
that help delight and make customers'
lives easier,
so. We've
been making continuous improvements and while
all the details are available in
our our AWS user guide for EKS
and there's a release notes page specifically, I
want to highlight some of the kind of most significant additions
that we've made over the last year and there's 6
key areas that we've been focusing on,
each in response to specific feedback that
we've been getting from our customers as they've
looked at auto mode,
thought about if they could use it and what they might need to adopt.
And so first I want to talk about expanded availability.
You know how we brought auto mode to new regions
including the US GovCloud and local zones, making
it accessible for public sector workloads and edge computing
use cases.
Next, we'll explore the advanced configuration
options that give you more control over
networking and security while maintaining the operational
simplicity that's core to EKS
Auto mode.
Then we'll dive a little bit deeper into that Sochi Parallel pole
feature
and explain how it automatically
is optimized for GPU instances and why it makes
it such a game changer for AIML workloads.
We'll also cover our enhanced security and compliance
capabilities that make it easier for
customers like Capital One to adopt auto
mode across large enterprises and highly regulated
industries.
After that, we'll discuss a couple of capacity
management features and then finally we'll
wrap up with thoughts about how all these work together
to continue to evolve Kubernete's
operations. So
first, one of the most requested features for
Auto mode has been broader regional availability,
especially for government and regulated workloads.
I'm excited to share that EKAS Automode is now available
in all the commercial regions where EKS is available
with the exception of the Abis China regions in Beijing
and Ningxia.
And in 2025 we expanded that to
include the AWS GovCloud regions, enabling
agencies and organizations with sensitive workloads
to take advantage of AutoMode's operational benefits
while meeting their compliance requirements.
It's a natural fit for AutoMode's
high operational and security bar.
Additionally,
this year we've brought Auto mode to AWS local
zones, allowing you to place Kuberne's
applications closer to your end users or on-premise
systems,
reducing latency while maintaining the
operational simplicity
that Automode provides. This has been particularly
valuable for customers running latency sensitive
applications like real-time analytics or perhaps games.
We've been significantly expanding
the configurations that are available in auto mode
without affecting its simplicity, and to be honest, this
has been one of the largest areas that we've
been investing in over the last year.
We took a very deliberate approach when we launched Auto
mode to have it have a relatively simple
set of configurations. That were available
and we wanted customers to come to us and tell us
what specific other knobs and buttons
they may need for it to be a good
fit for their use case and so
with that feedback we've been busy
answering and delivering those kinds of customizations
that customers need.
So first, and one of the most highly requested features
that we had for auto mode was the ability to
use separate subnets and security groups
for pods as opposed to nodes, which
you can now do through pod subnet
selector terms and pod security group selector
terms. This may not
be as familiar because when you're running when
you're trying to do this in a standard EKS cluster
through the VPCCNI, you do this through a mode called
custom networking.
This approach achieves the same thing but does
so in I think a little bit of a cleaner user
experience that's very similar to other kinds
of configurations that
you may be familiar with in auto mode.
We've also added a bunch of other advanced
networking configurations, things like
the ability to disable or enable
the ability to associate a public IP address
with the instances that Auto mode launches.
And being able to specify whether
or not the traffic on
leading nodes that auto mode launches
should be routed through a proxy
so you can specify that
certain destinations should be going through
a forward proxy,
whereas others shouldn't like local host destinations.
This is essential to support environments that
require this kind of proxy for outbound
connectivity or compliance reasons.
For customers, we've heard a lot that customers
needed to provide various private certificate
authority material to the nodes that
Auto mode runs to be able to authenticate
with other systems in their environment.
So you can now do this through the certificate
bundles parameter. This lets you
provide sort of a set
of public key material for
auto mode instances to use as they communicate
with other services in
your network.
This is particularly valuable for
organizations with internal PKI systems or
custom cert
authority requirements.
These additions make it so that
Autode's operational simplicity
is
paramount while still giving you the configuration
flexibility that you need to meet your specific
organization's requirements.
And I just wanna add one thing here folks.
It's like
when we launched Auto mode, uh, we
started listening to how customers were using it
and so I just wanna stress on something you said, Alex,
uh, you know, talk to us. We
will share with you our, our public road
map on Git GitHub.
I know Alex probably looks over
the, the, the issues on our road map every
day. It's probably in his morning routine.
So we, we really are listening and, uh,
tell us how you wanna use auto mode and.
He'll make it happen.
Uh yeah, and to be, that's exactly right. Like we, there's
a number of other things that we've already heard,
things that I think we'll hear in the future about if
only Auto mode would let me set X, Y, or
Z, it'd be a great fit for my use case. That's
exactly what we want to hear, and that kind of feedback is invaluable
for me as a product manager to figure out what we should
be doing next and, and how we can help enable our
customers to offload all of this kind
of operational burden that that AutoMode allows you
to um to delegate delegate to us. So
please keep it coming.
Um
We saw this live in size demo, the
Sochi Parallel image poll and unpacked, and this is a
common pain with containerized workloads, especially
those using for AIML
use cases where the time it
takes to download that image and unpack it
can delay really meaningful metrics for
these kinds of scenarios like time to first token,
and these are increasingly critical as
companies adopt more and more
AIML and inference
use cases.
We've addressed this, as Cy showed and mentioned,
by implementing the Sochi parallel container pole
and unpack capability, dramatically
reducing the startup time by parallellyzing
these operations for different layers in the container.
The best part,
as Cy mentioned, is that this is also automatically
enabled for every GPU enabled
instance in auto mode, as well as those that
don't have GPUs
but have local NVME storage.
So these are things like G series instances
from Size demo or the P
series with you know other like Nvidia
hardware, ranium instances,
as well as a variety of others that just happen to have
that really fast local
local MDME storage.
There's zero configuration required for this. We've
we've done a bunch of work to figure out what the right
settings are because there's a fair amount of them for Sochi
and applied them automatically
for the given instance that happens to be launched at that
moment. This drastically reduces
the container startup time as you saw in Size demo like what,
2 to 3 minutes down to like 1 minute and 15
seconds or something. Yeah, we've seen up to 60
and even sometimes higher percentage reduction
in the total pull time. Yeah,
um, and you know as your organizations
start to think about how they can, they can leverage AI,
uh, this will become, I think, an increasingly important
factor in, um, you know, how to,
how to serve those workloads quickly
and efficiently.
So you know Dan
Capital One works in a very highly regulated
industry, um,
a large, you know, a large requirement for compliance
and security for us is our top priority.
We've added several important capabilities
over the last year to make sure that Auto mode
can still can meet even the highest security standards.
So first and foremost, you can now encrypt
both the root volume and the data
volume of instances launched by
auto mode using custom encryption keys that you
provide. So these are like
KMS keys that you you you you
provide to AWS
and that will then allow you to encrypt
all of the data that resides on those
instances
for customers in regulated industries and as
part of the launch into the US GovCloud
regions. We've also enabled PIPS validated
cryptographic modules for
EKS Auto mode's controllers and
the instances that that we launch.
So this means that you can activate
these PIPS crypto cryptographic modules
using a setting in the node class for auto mode,
so advanced Security. Phipps,
um, and this will ensure that your clusters
comply with federal information
processing standards. So
a key thing for a lot of customers in the public. Sector
or that have customers of their own that are in the
public sector and run in these
gov cloud regions is to be able to
attest that their infrastructure meets
these requirements.
This is one piece in how you can help
enable that with just a single setting
in a YAML.
One of my favorite new features addresses a
common IAM challenge. So you
know Cy was alluding to how even seasoned
operators will struggle with getting
the right sets of IM resources stood
up, and you know often it's
a really sensitive operation to delegate
out to large swaths of an
organization. It may not be something that every
user in a given team
should be able to do, that is creating new IAM
roles or attaching various policies to them.
So you can now enable teams
to use auto mode without having to grant them those
additional permissions. They just need an instance
profile.
This simplifies the access management
and maintains your security posture.
I think that this is kind of a great example of a
sort of a real world example of
the principal lease privilege.
You don't really need someone to be able to create IM
roles to be able to launch auto
mode instances, just that instance profile.
And so if you, if you're in an
organization where there is very careful sort of
attention paid to the permissions that different
users or personas get.
Um, this will be a great feature that will make it that much
easier to get started with auto mode. You won't have to go ask your security
team for permissions they're gonna wanna, you
know, maybe think twice about giving you.
Instead, the very simple instance profile
is a great way to
to work around that.
These features are, I think, fundamentally
a reflection of our commitment to
security by default, which Auto mode has had since its
launch through the choice of bottle rocket, its operating
system and various other sort of security enhancements
that Autoode has, and we hope that it helps
give you the tools that you need to meet your own
security and compliance requirements.
So the last group of features that we
have here are around the capacity itself, so
like the instances in your cluster.
While Auto mode's dynamic capacity
management powered by Carpenter
is perfect for a lot of workloads, there
are absolutely scenarios that require more
predictable or reserved capacity.
So that's why we've added these two important
features around how Automode handles
capacity management.
So first, Automo can now prioritize
reserve capacity, so on-demand capacity
reservations or capacity blocks for ML,
which will help increase the cost efficiency of your
existing investments in these
these kind of like pre-purchased
options. You can configure this
using this new sort of stanza
in the you'll recognize a theme
here around terms, new stanza in the node class
capacity reservation selector terms.
This lets you target very flexibly
reservations by ID or via
tag
and will let auto mode say,
hey, if I can fulfill the
compute needs for a workload using reserve capacity,
it'll always try to do that first rather than spinning up
an on-demand or spot instance, for example.
So I mentioned auto mode
by default has this very kind of dynamic and
flexible compute management model powered by Carpenter,
but not all workloads need that kind of
dynamism,
and for that we've introduced a feature
we're calling static capacity.
So this is a very different style feature.
This makes capacity management in automode work very
differently than it does by default in that
you can tell us that you want to tell Aomode
that you want to have a
set number of instances always running.
Regardless of how many pods are in the cluster
or how many pods are pending, which is typically how
new instances come into an auto mode cluster,
this allows you to pre-provision capacity
independently
from
the workloads in your cluster and will ensure that
you always have the resources you need for
mission critical applications or those that
simply just don't need to auto scale.
Um, I think these features give you a lot more
control over how auto mode manages
capacity and maintains all
of the operational benefits that you get from auto mode,
you know, obviously helps you optimize for both performance
costs and your team's time, which is really critical.
So You know, as we
wrap up,
I, I wanna leave you with a few key takeaways
from our journey today and uh
through EKS Auto mode and, and kind of what it means for
how we think Kuberne's operations
looks in the future,
so. First,
Auto mode is a fundamental shift in how we think
about operating Kubernetes.
While 93% of organizations are using
or evaluating Kubernetes, the
operational complexity can be a significant challenge.
Um, EKS Autoode allows you to move
from manual,
complex cluster management, that that pain on
the the the the maze slide in in dance
section,
um, to a fully automated AWS
managed cluster infrastructure.
Second, this isn't just about reducing
operational overhead, it's about enabling innovation.
As Dan told us, when your platform teams
aren't constantly firefighting infrastructure
issues, they can focus on what really matters building
features that drive value for your business
and help, help you and the rest of your
organization innovate.
Third,
Automa maintains the power and flexibility of
Kubernetes while drastically simplifying
its complexity.
You still get full access to the entire Kubernes
ecosystem. Autoode's Kubernetes conform it.
Anything that you can do in Kubernetes, you can do in auto
mode, um.
But you just simply don't have to bear the burden of that
heavy operational lift
because it's Kubernis is important, all of those tools
continue to work seamlessly.
Finally,
enterprise requirements don't have to mean
operational complexity.
Automode is ready to meet your security, compliance,
and performance needs while keeping things
simple.
Whether you're just starting on your Kubernetes journey
or looking to modernize your existing platform,
Autode, give Automode a shot and tell us
how you think how it works out for you, and I
think you'll experience what we've been discussing here firsthand.
Thank you all so much. Thank you, Cy, Dan,
uh, and enjoy the rest of your reinvent.
Thank you. Thanks.